[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique je
suis ravi de vous retrouver à la une ce
soir la tournée africaine de la rolls
après le sénégal dimanche le chancelier
allemand était au niger il a été reçu
par mohamed bazoum il a notamment été
question des enjeux sécuritaires dans la
région les précisions de notre
correspondant harold girard au début de
ce journal
il ya un an le volcan nyiragongo dans
l'est de la république démocratique du
congo entre est en éruption plus de 3000
maisons avaient été détruites par la
lave nous verrons quelles leçons ont été
tirées de cette catastrophe
et puis nous irons à abidjan pour le
salon du livre qui s'est tenue après
trois ans d'absence la dictée
intergénérationnelle a elle aussi fait
son retour alors à vos stylos à la fin
de ce journal
c'est sa première visite en afrique
depuis son élection en allemagne la
chose s'est d'abord rendu au sénégal le
chancelier allemand a été reçu par le
chef de l'état macky sall aussi
président en exercice de l'union
africaine les questions économiques
étaient au coeur de cette rencontre les
pays du continent sont notamment très
impactées par la guerre en ukraine
l'allemagne pour sa part cherche à
diversifier ses approvisionnements en
énergie et le sénégal dispose justement
de gnl de gaz naturel liquéfié mais pas
à n'importe quel prix écoutez ce qu'en
disait macky sall
nous sommes prêts nous on se régale en
tout cas à travailler dans une
perspective d'alimenter le marché
européen gêne
les conditions là vous l'avez dit il
faut un accompagnement dans ce jugement
en exploitation dans notre prise de
participation à des conditions
meilleures que celles qui sont
aujourd'hui gonnehem au sénégal et avant
de se rendre en afrique du sud lundi
soir le chancelier allemand s'est arrêté
à niamey au niger cette fois les
discussions avec mohamed bazoum portait
sur l'accord de coopération militaire
qui lie les deux pays il s'agit de la
mission et gazelle l'allemagne sur la
formation des forces spéciales
nigérienne et puis le retrait du mali
des pays du g5 ça elle a aussi été
longuement commenté notre correspondant
à un rôle gérard a suivi pour nous cette
visite
olaf scholz paraissait cet après midi à
niamey réellement contrarié de
l'attitude des autorités maliennes il a
tenu à réaffirmer son soutien au projet
minus mal un des seuls encore viable en
ce moment sur le sol malien alors même
que mohammed bazoum le président
nigérien le féliciter de son soutien
continu quant à la formation des soldats
nigériens par des soldats allemands lui
a préféré rebondir sur le désengagement
du mali voisin de l'organisation g5
c'est l'allemagne comme la france
envisage un redéploiement d'une partie
de sa force armée du mali vers le niger
mais comme plusieurs partenaires
européens de la nation de mohamed bazoum
et bien toujours pas de déclarations sur
la nature exacte du renforcement de
l'assistance militaire dans le pays
la situation sécuritaire au sahel est
très difficile nous comptons continuer
de contribuer à la mission des nations
unies ici la mini sma il faut vraiment
une bonne coopération
si on veut assurer la sécurité dans la
région
la situation empire du fait de la
présence de mercenaires russes au mali
une bonne coopération est donc d'autant
plus importante
quand l'allemagne et le niger
la dégradation de la situation
sécuritaire au mali impact déjà très
fortement le niger en ce moment c'est
l'afflux de réfugiés du mali vers le
niger le plus fort enregistré par les
autorités locales depuis plus de dix ans
malgré que la frontière malienne soit
une priorité pour le secteur de la
sécurité ici dans le pays est bien dans
le même temps les groupes armés
terroristes basés au burkina faso
sévissent de plus en plus régulièrement
depuis le début de l'année 2022 sur les
zones nigérienne frontalière du burkina
justement et de l'autre côté une
résurgence de l'état islamique en libye
fait craindre une prochaine
déstabilisation du nord-est du niger la
situation militaire a dégradé dans la
zone des trois frontières c'est
justement ce qui avait notamment
précipité la chute du président
burkinabè à roch marc christian kaboré
renversé par des militaires accusés
d'être inefficace face à la violence
djihadiste et ce dimanche le président
de la transition burkina faso le
lieutenant-colonel damiba s'est rendu
sur le lieu d'une attaque de djihadistes
présumés contre des militaires dans le
nord du pays au cours de laquelle cinq
d'entre eux ont été tués le président
damiba rendu hommage aux soldats décédés
il a par ailleurs appelé les djihadistes
à déposer les armes
lui aussi a été renversé par les
militaires l'ancien président guinéen
alpha condé s'est envolé samedi pour la
turquie pour y recevoir des soins il a
été autorisé à quitter le territoire par
les autorités au pouvoir alpha condé qui
fait l'objet je vous le rappel de
poursuites judiciaires comme nous le
rappelle notre correspondant maliki
d'équité à conakry
selon plusieurs médias locaux qui ont
largement relayé l'information alpha
condé a quitté conakry samedi peu avant
10 heures à destination de la turquie
aucun détail n'a filtré sur l'état de
santé de l'ancien président nie aucune
précision sur la durée de ce séjour
médical selon le communiqué publié
vendredi par le cnrd les militaires au
pouvoir ce déplacement s'inscrit dans le
souci du respect rade dignité et de
l'intégrité et de l'ancien président et
pour des raisons humanitaires les
autorités expliquant que c'est une
décision prise en parfaite conformité
avec les procédures judiciaires
intentées contre l'ex président alpha
condé de piment alpha condé et vingt six
anciens rocade re de son régime sont
poursuivis par la justice pour des faits
présumés d'assassinats d'attac de tortue
et d'enlèvement qui auraient été commis
entre 2019 et 2020 lors des
manifestations contre son troisième
mandat les ong de défense de droits de
l'homme exprime déjà la nécessité d'un
retour rapide de l'ancien président afin
de faire face à la justice
c'était il ya un an l'éruption du volcan
nyaragongo dans l'est de la république
démocratique du congo la lave s'était
arrêté aux portes de la ville de goma
mais plus de 3000 maisons avaient été
détruites
l'éruption avait mis en évidence le
manque de préparation des autorités
un an après nos envoyés spéciaux clément
bonnerot juste un an kaboom barre et
juliette du bois sont retournés sur
place
l'oca dia a perdu sa maison lors de
l'éruption du 22 mai 2021 un an après
elle vit toujours dans ce camp de
fortune avec ses 6 ans
voilà sur quoi nous dormons s'est ennuyé
à cause de la pluie voilà comment nous
souffrons il faut raisonner en legs side
event boucle si la plupart des sinistrés
ont emménagé dans de nouvelles maisons
500 familles attendent encore d'être
relogés comme look à dire à merveille
dit avoir perdu espoir
personne n'est venu nous aider
le président tshisekedi d'arriver ici
mais comme d'habitude c'est toujours de
promesses jusque là papa l'herbe au
lendemain de l'éruption le gouvernement
congolais avait promis de tout faire
pour mieux se préparer à une nouvelle
catastrophe l'ovj l'observatoire
volcanologique de goma avait notamment
dit manquer de moyens pour travailler
depuis de nouveaux investissements ont
été réalisés comme ce laboratoire
bon et si nous en prenons
pour mieux surveiller le volcan le
gouvernement à doter le vg de quatre
stations d'observation supplémentaires
mais certains équipements sont toujours
inutilisable comme cette sirène d'
alerte
[Musique]
il y en ont les habitants avaient fuit
goma de manière désordonnée la
protection civile se dit aujourd'hui
mieux préparé ces jeux de simulation été
distribués dans les écoles de la ville
les oranje ici c'est le marché installé
la route aussi les autorités promettent
aussi des formations la protection
civile va former des organisations
communautaires des réponses aux urgences
qui sera à mesure d'identifier et signe
dalet départager les allaite avec les
numéros de la protection civile
un nouveau plan de contingence devrait
être rendu public avant la fin du mois
de juin
est toujours en rdc sur le plan
politique cette fois c'est peut-être le
miracle de la messe la poignée de main
entre les deux ennemis d'hier joseph
kabila et moïse katumbi dans la
cathédrale saints pierre et paul de
lubumbashi sous les applaudissements
vous voyez est ce le début de la
réconciliation entre les deux hommes
originaires du katanga est peut-être le
début d'une annonce politique à
l'approché des élections en attendant de
connaître la réponse le président lui
tshisekedi ait achevé sa visite
officielle de trois jours au burundi où
il a été reçu en grande pompe par le
président boulonnais evariste dash signé
et je vous le disais en titre après
trois ans d'absence la grand-messe du
livre d'abidjan étaient de retour du 17
au 21 mai dernier l'occasion pour les
organisateurs et participants de redorer
le blason de la littérature ivoirienne
et africaine alors que le secteur est de
plus en plus menacés par de nouvelles
sources de contenu digital voyez ce
reportage de nos correspondants à
d'affaires gianni et damien koffi c'est
l'un des événements les plus hauts l'ère
du salon du livre d'abidjan la dictée
intergénérationnelle pète elle aussi son
retour au palais de la culture pour
cette nouvelle édition ils sont plus de
300 à se prêter à l'exercice
et comme le veut la tradition chaque
copie reste anonyme de façon décomplexée
on invite les jeunes les moins jeunes
les plus âgées à venir s'exercer à
l'autographe c'est aussi une façon de
contribuer à la promotion au
développement de l'industrie nationale
de l'édition du livre et de la lecture
cette année la dictée a également lieu
simultanément dans cinq villes de
l'intérieur du pays avec pour seul mot
d'ordre redonner le goût du verbe aux
populations dans les couloirs du salon
des stands de livres à perte de vue des
séances de dédicaces des écrivains de
renommée mais aussi de tout nouveaux
auteurs comme cette coach professionnel
qui a récemment adopté la plume pour
partager son expérience avec un public
plus large je pense qu'on va vers une
nouvelle ère
vers une nouvelle ère et les gens
commencent à se dire que
ok on aime s'amuser
mais en parallèle on peut aussi
apprendre et puis réussir
professionnellement le livre de da steve
est disponible sur la plateforme limba
une maison d'édition spécialisée dans
les récits africain et une offre en
panne avec un lectorat plus jeune la
diffusion est double elle est à la fois
physique mais elle est aussi numérique
et donc pour ce faire on a on a un
partenariat avec une biotech numérique
qui s'appelle le scribe qui permet à
tout un chacun quel que soit l'endroit
où il est sur le territoire ivoirien ou
dans la sous région en afrique
francophone d'avoir accès à
l'intégralité de notre catalogue pour
100 francs par jour pour toucher le plus
grand nombre cette élite rice venu de
guadeloupe proposent elles des
expériences exclusivement audio sur nos
territoires on est pratiquement à 40 %
de taux d'illettrisme quand je discute
avec des responsables ici c'est plus de
la moitié de la population de la côte
d'ivoire qui est en situation
d'illettrisme est ce que c'est pour
autant qu'il faut le remplir les
empêcher de lire selon les organisateurs
cette édition du retour a accueilli près
de cent mille visiteurs un engouement
qui prouve que le livre a encore de
beaux jours devant lui
et c'est la fin du joint de l'afrique
merci de votre fidélité et rester avec
nous l'information continue
c'est parti pour la 75e édition du
festival de cannes après deux années
perturbées par le coville le cinéma est
à nouveau roi sur la croisette avec du
beau monde sur le tapis rouge tom cruise
marion cotillard ou encore david
cronenberg interview avec des
personnalités direct tout au long de la
journée et notamment pendant la montée
des marches france 24 va vous faire
vivre ce rendez vous incontournable du
septième art
vivez en direct le festival de cannes
sur france 24 et france 24 points comme
retrouver la météo avec les cafés
malongo acteurs du commerce équitable
chez malongo ce sont les petits
producteurs qui font les grands cafés le
coeur des hommes bâton malongo